Eighty per cent
of the British population
say they visit a fish and chip shop
at least once a year,
and we consume 382 million meals
from the chippie per annum.
That’s pretty impressive
for a combination that’s only
been with us for around 150 years –
for the first fish and chip shop
only appeared in around 1860.
Separately, both fried fish, and
chips, were enjoyed by the British
well before they came together.
Chips as a term for something edible
was in use in the 18th Century,
often in relation, rather curiously,
to oranges -
orange chips
were candied chunks of peel.
It was in the same century
that the potato was going from
knobbly curiosity to staple food,
especially for the poor,
and given how well potatoes
lend themselves to deep frying,
it was inescapable that potato chips
would soon be on the scene.
By the Victorian era,
chipped potatoes were everywhere,
from the delicate little
‘straw potatoes’ -
which resembled, well, straw -
eaten by the rich,
to the French street food,
which Dickens described as
“husky chips of potatoes fried
with some reluctant drops of oil”.
The British preferred baked potatoes,
but they ate them fried too.
Fried fish, meanwhile, was also on
the tables of the rich and the poor.
Bread-crumbed filets,
delicately fried in butter
and garnished with fried parsley,
were a staple for upmarket meals.
Whitebait, fried in lard, were
considered a delicious delicacy.
But there was another place
fried fish could be bought,
and that was the street -
in the Jewish quarters
of London and other big cities.
There, Sephardic Jews
sold cold fried fish
intended for eating on the Sabbath
when no cooking was allowed
in Jewish homes.
It quickly took off,
being cheap, filling and tasty,
and fried fish shops and
market stalls - hot and cold -
sprung up in cities across the UK.
It was inevitable
that these two street foods,
so popular with the masses, would
end up being sold in combination.
It proved a winning formula and fish
and chip shops took off immediately.
Trawl fishing and the
railway boom of the 1870s
helped fish to reach inland
areas quicker than ever before,
and potatoes were already
grown everywhere.
By 1910 there were 25,000 fish and
chip shops in the UK,
and by 1929 there were 10,000 more.
Such was the hold of fish and chips -
and its genuine goodness,
especially for its mainly
working-class consumers -
that during the Second World War,
fish and chips
remained off the ration,
though the type of fish available
was not always the most delicious
or desirable of species.
Across the UK, accompaniments vary -
from the mushy peas of the north,
to curry sauce, ketchup, mayonnaise
or the chip shop spice
which is on every counter in Hull.
Salt and vinegar remain the staples.
In the 21st Century chippie,
vegetable fats have often replaced
beef dripping or lard for frying.
Newspaper used to be
the wrapping of choice - outlawed,
unless fresh from the printers and
unsullied by readers’ hands, in 1968.
Now it’s mainly plain paper
and polystyrene,
but the skillful wrapping and
excitement of unwrapping remains.
There are, however, fish and chips…
and fish and chips.
Witness the disappointment
on the faces of tourists,
lured by the promise
of a great British delicacy,
only to find they’ve happened
upon the bad version,
all grease and soggy batter.
But then when it’s good…
well, it’s crispy and fluffy, with a
hit of vinegar, and a punch of salt.
It's unbeatable.